[Music]
welcome so reason was traditionally seen
as the Enlightenment's great legacy and
the origins of our success yet reason is
increasingly derided as does the
rhetorical bluster of the educated elite
typically powerful and male is
rationality just the prejudice claims of
those who are sure they are right will
be mistaken
to think that weaves and drives progress
or is it an unassailable tool for social
harmony and future flourishing let me
introduce our speakers for this event so
Mary Jane Rubinstein is professor of
religion at Wesleyan University in
Connecticut her research interests
include gender and the relationship
between science and religion
Paul Bogosian is silver professor of
philosophy at New York University he's
an expert in realism
relativism and constructivism and he's
the author of fear of knowledge against
relativism and constructivism and
finally but not last but not least is
Alister McGrath who's andreas areas
professor of science and religion at
Oxford and director of the Ian Ramsey
Centre for science and religion so Mary
Jane perhaps you can kick things off is
rationality just the prejudice claim of
those who think they all rights ok I'm
going to jump right in good afternoon
everybody it's wonderful to see you
thank you for being here and I'm going
to say no it's a lot worse than that for
mainline Western philosophy rationality
is said to be the mark of the human and
as such it promises wonderful things
like equal rights neutral judgement the
nonviolent exchange of ideas so I can
see the attraction the problem is I'd
like to say that the category of
humanity that's defined by means of
rationality is less a force of capacious
'no sand equality than of exclusion and
domination three examples very quickly
first the rationality still said to
distinguish the human from every of
species justifies the unconditional
exploitation of the whole earth toward
human ends it's their alleged
irrationality that condemns cows
chickens pigs and goats to mass deaths
that feeds and clothes us and that
allows whales and dolphins and seabirds
to be suffocated by the plastic bags
that make our lives a little easier
second rationality sets humans apart
from those whom Aristotle called natural
slaves which is to say people who don't
think so well and who therefore need to
be guided or as the later tradition
understood owned by others
this logic and it is a logic of natural
slavery was applied to those Africans
who were stuffed into transatlantic
cargo carriers in the 16th century
giving rise to what Frank will derson
exposes as a glaring contradiction
between the Enlightenment obsession with
freedom and its condoning or even
justification of slavery this legacy
continues in the u.s. especially to
subject black bodies to constant
surveillance serial imprisonment and
execution by an over armed police force
third the category of rationality
justifies the ongoing global subjection
of women and by extension queer and
gender non-conforming people thanks to
their insufficient reason Thomas Aquinas
called women misbegotten
men 19th century psychiatrists diagnosed
them as hysterical you know with wounds
travelling all over the plate 'yes I
need baby and contemporary discourse
still encodes women as tending
excessively toward emotion in the u.s.
around Hillary Clinton either she was
too emotional to rule or too calculating
to be a woman so I have nothing again
I've nothing against the Faculty of
reason I'm presumably using it right now
but categorically rationality has
functioned to secure a cosmic hierarchy
that condemns non-white non male and
non-human lives to belittlement
exploitation and deaths rendering them
frankly incapable of delivering a
rational set of objections to that
situation
the bulb starts Paul is rationality just
the prejudice claim of those who think
they're right no not and it's alarming
to hear that it could even be thought to
be you know we have to distinguish with
regard to any concept the concept itself
from uses and abuses of that concept so
you know there is everybody knows that
on the gate at Auschwitz there was the
inscription was our bite macht frei so
there the concept of freedom there was
being abused that doesn't just because
somebody put the concept of freedom to
the bad use doesn't mean that the
concept itself is objectionable or the
the the aims that the concepts observes
are objectionable so just as Mary Jane
just now said presumably she was
claiming that various of the things that
she was pointing out as abuses of the
concept of rationality that it's
rational for us to believe that they
were abuses of the concept of
rationality there is no escaping this
the notion of rationality in its bare
form is just the idea of being
responsive in your management of your
beliefs to what reasons there are for
believing those things okay so to that
extent no one can escape even when you
want to say I am a skeptic about
rationality you give an argument and you
hope the argument persuades by showing
you that it's rational to believe it so
at the end of the day there really is no
real question about whether you need to
rely on reason what are you going to do
rely on whistling or rely on music to
the extent to which what you're
interested in is making a case for the
truth of what you believe you have to
present reasons for that belief and they
have to be epistemic reasons not just
Prudential reasons or aesthetic reasons
or moral reasons they have to be reasons
that show that the belief has some
chance of
true that's goes for any belief even as
you ascend the hierarchy of the most
abstract or meta beliefs that are
themselves about the concepts of reason
and logic and so on the only really
interesting question there can be is a
rational debate about what the correct
rules of rationality are and the great
achievement of the Enlightenment was to
see that with respect to a whole range
of subject matters in particular what we
call empirical subject matters the
correct rules of rational belief
fixation or what we know is the
scientific method okay and the use of
logic rather than for instance
theological speculation or other kinds
of a priori prejudice that might one
might bring to the table so I believe
that over and over again if the light
motif of this debate will be there is no
escaping the clutches as it were of
rationality and it is no part of the
notion of rationality that you should
subject blacks or women to oppression or
that you should do any of the bad things
that Mary Jane was highlighted Thank You
Alastair would you like well I I very
much hope the reason will deliver us
from things that are wrong but I have my
worries about this argue I once says
this we are able to reason but that form
of reasoning is shaped by the enterprise
our undertaking
each scientific discipline uses reason
in different ways there's different
criteria of rationalization each culture
and their supports are suppressed by
some other culture will develop its own
way of thinking and for me talking about
reason is is that rational faculties but
it does not necessarily mean that you
have the delivered outcomes with
certainty that kind of we bind us all
together so I look at the Enlightenment
I which I I have great respect for by
also note the problems that we find for
examples you were the French
enlightenment Dalembert in his very
interesting preface in encyclopedia
talks about the importance of Reason but
then when pressed up what the right we
form is he identifies a sociological
group they both discreetly the good guys
who in effect show us what is the reason
and that's why I think it's such a good
question because in effect it's all
about sociological privilege Aristotle
talked about the wise meaning these guys
are getting tell the rest of us what's
right and I think we need to be very
very skeptical about that Thomas Hobbes
leading figure of the Enlightenment said
look when we talk about right reason of
course we mean the way I think and
that's the issue really so for me
there's a real concern here we perhaps
think and forget that that for example
there's a lot of uniformity you're
thinking but very often this is because
of the influence of Western pressure
very often perpetuate by colonialism so
it seems to me that we do indeed have
reason well I'm with Pascal the great
achievement of reason is to show its
limits and that's where the instant
conversation starts okay so quite
diverse opening positions there and so
let's move on to our first theme which
is what's wrong with reason now Mary
Jane e-40 giving us a little taster of
what you think is wrong with reason
perhaps you could develop that well
right so as Paul was saying of course I
have nothing again against the Faculty
of Reason clearly worth having some kind
of rational conversation at the moment
and it's an it's absurd to claim that
somehow you can make a rational argument
that somehow escapes you from that gets
you out of the logic rush now what's
wrong with reason I think is the way
historically that it's been deployed as
a tool of belittlement and derision and
even enslavement and all the rest so
it's I so I think that any kind of
coming to terms with or any defense of
the importance of rationality at least
needs to come to terms with the history
of its categorical deployment that's
just one one bit of it I'll stop there
would you agree with that Paul well I
mean there's there's no question that to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you